[Music]  as women stand up for freedom and  fairness from Iran to Ukraine the  European Parliament is marking its  gender equality week with special events  and debates on building a just Society  for all Parliament is fighting to  improve gender equality by ending  gender-based violence and ensuring  better access to sexual and reproductive  health  MEPS are demanding action on the gender  pay Gap and energy poverty among women  as well as proper recognition for unpaid  and underpaid care work  Parliament wants to empower women in the  job market ensure equal access to  leadership positions and guarantee  gender balance in EU institutions and  Beyond everyone regardless of gender  should be treated equally and get the  same opportunities  [Music]